dna is perfect for the storage and
readout of genetic information
this information is stored in the
sequence of adenine thymine
guanine and cytosine also called a t g
and c
each helix has a backbone made of
alternating deoxyribose and phosphate
groups
readout occurs in three prime to five
prime direction making use of the
pairing of bases between the opposing
strands of the dna double helix in these
pairings a pairs with t and g pairs with
c via sets of complementary hydrogen
bonds
the edges of the base pairs are exposed
in the two grooves of the double helix
the wider major groove and the narrower
minor groove
these edges are also used to carry
information that is read by proteins
that interact with the double helix
prime example of a dna double helix is
pdb entry 1bna
upon printing the dna folding template
you will notice that it contains two
types of models
in this model you can add your own base
pairs but be sure to pair them up
properly
this detailed model shows all the atoms
in each nucleotide
in this tutorial we will use the smaller
model for the demonstration however the
technique is the same for both models
first cut out the model
fold all long solid gray lines so that
each solid line is visible on the top
edge of the crease that is made
fold all long dotted gray lines so that
each long dotted line is hidden within
the crease that is made
fold the paper in half so that the outer
two backbone columns stack one over the
other
tuck the other backbone flaps with five
prime at the top one over the other
next
temporarily fold the backbones so that
the model is flat
crease the horizontal and diagonal lines
solid lines should be visible on the top
edge of each crease with dotted lines on
the inside
you can crease them in any order you
like folding and unfolding each intern
one good way to do it is to crease all
of the horizontal lines then flip the
model over and crease all of the
diagonal lines
the result should look sort of like a
paper fan
using the creases that you just made
fold out triangles that stack on top of
each other but not directly
this way the triangle beneath the one
just folded should rotate a little bit
further clockwise and as this process
continues the triangles in the spiraling
ladder will form the circle structure
your model should look like this when
all the lines have been folded
pull the model open and pop out the
backbones on the sides
your finished model is a right-handed
double helix
you can use the tabs to connect several
models to make longer strands
to learn more about dna go to pdb 101.